happy friday everybody we are taking a
live look at the welcome to las vegas
sign you can see the lights around it
are flashing
red this morning and it is for a very
special cause you're gonna see that uh
several properties on the strip also
going to be in red today and a lot of us
are wearing red today as well john
indeed it is the american heart
association's go red for women day alex
yeah and john sherry nate myself diane
girl we're in red today
uh to bring awareness to this very
important cause absolutely it's very
important to raise awareness that's why
the american heart association is doing
this
heart disease and strokes in women the
number one killer
of women in the nation doctors say 80
percent of those deaths
could have been prevented the
association says one in three women will
die from heart disease
doctors say heart attack symptoms can be
different for women than men
now you're looking there at a 30 year
old professional dancer she explains
what it felt like
when she had a heart attack it felt like
an intense pressure from gas and
so i tried to deal with it by myself not
knowing
blood was not getting to my heart so
once i got to the hospital they told me
that part of my heart had died
doctors say knowing your body mass index
your blood sugar your blood pressure
and your cholesterol numbers it is key
to staying heart
healthy